the killing of george floyd
ignited worldwide protest and calls for
change
but the epicenter of the outrage was
here
an unassuming suburb of minneapolis
the crossroads where he died now known
as george floyd square
remains closed off almost frozen in time
at the moment the world saw a black man
dying
under
[Applause]
[Music]
eliza calls herself the square's
gatekeeper
i've been out here from day one since
george ford died i have not stopped not
one time
rain snow falls asleep i told him i'll
be here and i'm going to be here
the trial we will be here we're going to
have projectors here
but the people's in the community we all
can sit together we can watch the trial
we can cry together we can reap together
we can talk together we can hold one
another we can comfort one another
and how concerned are you about the
outcome of the trial
about what might happen if people don't
feel they have had justice
well like i said we all gonna feel the
same way
we know justice ain't gonna go the way
we want to go
the lives of almost everyone you meet
here feel touched by his death
this is the convenience store that
called the police after george floyd
allegedly used a fake twenty dollar bill
please tell the clerk who called the
police it was not their fault
this one how does it feel to hear that
it feels uh i mean it's it's the truth
the owner samir shows us some of the
letters they've received from around the
world
uh this one i don't know where it came
from
but it says
dear complicit
you're complicit in george floyd death
kind of not clear but it says you
call the cops over 20 bills shame on you
and now a man is dead this one says it's
from a lady
it says dear mahmoud and employees you
have my heart
felt sympathy it's horrible that you got
caught up in this
murder this is the responsibility
emotion is still raw
but i think either way we're going to
burn our city down i don't
see either if you got 100 years if you
got 10 years it wouldn't matter
and do you think anything's changed no
no nearly 10 months on
there's a really strong sense here that
nothing's really changed when it comes
to the treatment of black people by
police
and a real sense of apprehension about
the outcome
of derek shauvin's trial no white police
officer
has ever been convicted for the death of
a black person in minnesota
this time the eyes of the world are
watching
but hope is fragile that george floyd's
death
may change the course of history
sally lockwood sky news minneapolis